being nominated for this year's class of  the legion of doom  if she could only just stop leaving crew  members behind we didn't leave anybody  oh [ __ ]  [Music]  daryl if you ever bring me inferior  toilet wine again i'll be forced to  shank you in the showers and you know i  don't want to do that  i like being cool balls  hey king i am so sorry for leaving you  here so long oh no problem it allowed me  to experience firsthand the felons of  the prison industrial complex  [Applause]  now fellas look i know it's just in fun  but what the [ __ ] did i tell you about  that world oh yeah sorry king sorry  about that oh  they're learning baby steps right harley  i will kill each and every one of you  with my bare hands if i have to